just say for me I am in love I'm in love
I am in love I am in love I am in love I
am in LA I know hello everybody I am
Colby rebel I am a professional psychic
medium everyone wants to know about
their love life it's always fun to tune
in so I'm very excited to see what
happens today I'll start with you yeah
what's your name
destiny destiny yes hi destiny how you
doing I'm good how are you I am good are
you in love yeah have you feel like you
met your soul mate I think so maybe do
you feel like you've known them a long
time yeah how long is a long time for
you anything past two years how long
you've been with this person three how
did you meet this person through my
mom's Sorority big tall and handsome
mm-hmm strong the city used to play
football but they have a really good
voice it feels like a deep voice and it
was hard at first wasn't it mm-hmm okay
thank you
yeah hi there what's your first name
Chester Lake Francesca but Jess Cheska
yeah how you feel about love I feel like
mainly it is a decision but yeah like
people fall in love but at the end if
you decide to stay with each other yeah
then there's a lot more like logical
reason right right I feel like you have
a partner would you understand the
partner being somewhat feminine all
right okay yeah I was just seeing
someone who wanted to make sure their
nails were done and like someone a
little pampering you didn't pepper his
nails but yeah he did it does cut his
nails and then you would also understand
the two of you you don't fight much
actually with this person it feels like
it's usually pretty peaceful is that
right
yeah like when we fight it's petty
things
when's your anniversary
april-ish we don't really have a clear
anniversary why not we don't have like
oh this is when we decided to be
together did it feel like a friend at
first
I was attracted to him right away but we
started out as friends okay
okay got it okay thank you ah you hi
there what's your first name Lara I look
you look like a Lara actually that name
fits you do you feel in love right now
like a little bit okay and then would
you understand searching for love yes
and you understand like almost a
disappointment around it would that be
correct yeah and like a sense of just
foster I feel like a sense of
frustration like I almost feel like
there was someone you were dating not
too long going you were a little
optimistic about it but it might be 2 or
3 months but then it doesn't really feel
like it lasted does that make sense to
you
yeah sorry any I just want to help you
with that relationship because I just it
just feels like it's over yeah and it
just feels like it's it's okay to be
past it but I also feel like you would
want a relationship does that make sense
to you and and I also feel like you're
really looking for someone that listens
well maybe that's been a little bit of
trouble for you finding someone that
isn't all about themselves yeah you know
what I'm saying okay
all right Thank You Laura oh how about
you honey hi there how are you oh good
good good are you feeling good about
love do you feel happy in love
do you wish you were in love yeah okay
and have you been married before
no but you want to be married I don't
know all right thank you how about you
all right there hey what's your first
name for me
Jasmine Jasmine how you doing sweetheart
good how are you I'm good are you
excited to be here yeah are you excited
to talk about love yeah do you feel like
you're in love very much so and are you
happy very all right thank you very much
are you excited for love I don't know
are you hoping to find love I have love
are you just not sure if it's D love
that's part of it have you talked about
marriage
mm-hmm do you feel like you'll get
married yeah do you feel like you've
been together a while technically I'm
just kind of curious to would there be a
break in this relationship is that right
okay and this break wasn't too long ago
is that correct did this just happen
late last month or something like that
within the month riday okay so within a
week then right the interesting thing
let me just tell you I think this guy's
going to come back I think this guy's
gonna try to reach back out my only
concern for you is he honestly he feels
to be a little non-committal so I would
just be cautious to kind of saying yeah
okay let's do it again cuz I feel like
whenever he gets really stressed and he
has to make that commitment kind of talk
I feel like he starts to backwalk a
little bit is this the second break that
you've had yes yeah so anyhow that's a
sign for you all right all right thank
you first of all their souls are amazing
like these women are beautiful women
they're all like amazingly kind women
and they're amazingly like giving in
their life like you can just tell they
all want to kind of help people so that
I love seeing we just have to kind of
see if I get it right on the
relationship status
I will start with you yes please thank
you and maybe just the first thing to
say to me is I am in love I'm in love my
feeling is is that you are in a
relationship I felt like you are and I
really felt like this person is a really
good connection for you
would I be right that you are in a
relationship yes okay yeah it wasn't
just immediate like I feel like you had
a little bit of walls up or they had I
just feel like they had to earn it a bit
I don't think you just gave it and
you're right from between the two of us
I'm the more cynical yes I think this
guy either has soft hands or likes work
he's just so gentle there's a gentleness
to him does that make sense around him
yeah he's a very sweet yeah that's kind
of what I was getting we're married
okay been together for like okay the
feminine one like made me laugh because
it's a yeah he is very in touch with his
like feminine yeah yeah okay okay all
right let's try you honey just say for
me I am in love I am in love okay I feel
like there is a man I think he likes
himself a lot I do I don't think he's
afraid of like poof in his chest out or
almost like a football player I feel
like there may be a little distance
maybe you want to live with him but
there's there's still feels to be some
physical distance I believe oh I don't
want to ruin anything I believe that
there's an engagement or an engagement
ring but I don't know if he's actually
done that yet or not I don't want to
ruin it oh my god if he did it because I
have ruined engagements before are you
technically engaged yet or no not yeah
okay but you know this is the one right
mm-hmm okay
he knows you're the one to I believe I
believe I just ruined and engagement
don't tell I don't I mean you're totally
right spot right on everything I'm in a
long-distance relationship for the past
three years he's a former college
football player oh well thank you very
much I appreciate it thank you
how about you oh I would just want you
to say for me I am in love I am in love
I want you to say for me I want love I
want love I can be right I don't feel
like you're married
I feel like you're single I feel like
you're single and I feel like there is
someone around or was someone around I
think I feel like you you want it to be
there you want it to be right but it
just still feels to me I get a little up
in the air about this one does that make
sense are you technically single do you
understand that there being someone
around that you really care about or
that you really have a heart connection
to does that make sense yeah okay do you
want a little something on him are you
sure okay
I do feel like he really cares about you
like when I go to try to talk about him
do you see how I pause or I pull back I
feel like there's a little bit of him
that either pause it
pauses or pulls back this is either too
soon or we're not sure where we are I
don't think he's a hundred percent sure
yet as to where this is going to go if
it wasn't possible he wouldn't be with
you it's building and it's growing and I
feel like it's something to let
yourselves explore without getting too
nervous about it of what's going to
happen like try not to get too into your
head about it so now you tell me so I'm
single but I'm showing that someone on
vacation okay okay good when he comes to
see you just let yourself to try to
relax around it you are nervous about it
and in a good way
I want you to be open to him all right
so good luck with this okay good luck
all right how about you I am in love I
am in love I know you do feel like
you're in love I gotta say I gotta tell
you I really feel like you're with your
soul mate I'm almost surprised that
you're not already married I mean I
think I would have thought you to be
already married my advice in this is
when you are kind of seeing things
differently try not to be quite so shut
down or closed down like I feel like
that's one thing that maybe I would
encourage you to kind of stay a little
open am i right that you're not
technically married is that right yes I
feel like this is a great great partner
for you
I believe this guy's in it for for the
lifetime I've been seeing my boyfriend
for six years okay we did long-distance
for four years okay he's my first
boyfriend
how wonderful good it's gonna be great
yeah you're welcome
well done I am gonna
I'm gonna do you she looks so
uncomfortable who drunk her in here just
look at me and say I am in love okay say
it again I am in love I feel like you're
single this is a tough one you know what
you're married aren't you
is that right yes yeah I'm saying I'm
okay there's got to be something with
this relationship because I'm feeling
like you're the only one where I feel
like it's so it's so off for me because
when I said I felt like you were single
I heard no she's not that means that's a
loved one talking to me for you that
you're not single it so you have to be
in order you have to be seeing someone
am i right that you're seeing someone oh
I should have gone with the first one
you're not seeing someone right now can
I look into this a little bit more for
you okay because your relationship feels
soon to me so I feel like the feeling
I'm getting of upside down is I feel
like once this relationship comes in it
is going to turn you upside down I don't
think you're gonna know what to do with
it I really feel like you're going to
kind of spin a lot and and in a good way
it doesn't feel a real negative way you
give the vibe of not being fully open so
that might just be that you protect your
heart or you're afraid of opening your
heart to understand that yes and so I
think when someone approaches you try to
like breathe through it and keep that
heart open so that they have a chance
because I think if they feel the way I
felt they won't even ask you out
I mean I am single like I don't know if
I want a relationship like I'm I am
afraid of rejection yeah I do feel like
there was a heartbreak in the past I I
don't know I keep seeing something in
the past of you okay so but you
understand that right because I keep
hearing this is all connect that this is
connected to this so I don't want you to
be too afraid okay sound good yeah okay
thank you
all right Missy hi there I think at the
moment technically if we're technical
we're single a technically but I do
think that there's been a back-and-forth
in a relationship my feeling is is that
it's not quite over there either
reaching back out or they're trying to
reconnect or trying to reignite
and again my only caution to that is I
think if they're gonna do it then
they're just gonna have to kind of stand
up a little bit more well first of all
it's weird because a lot of the stuff
that you were saying to other people
that maybe didn't quite land I was like
I think that was for me okay okay got it
are you married or single I'm
technically single okay I got it
we were together for basically three
years yeah we broke up sometime in the
middle we got back together and then he
moved to Seattle a month ago okay
and we were doing long-distance and then
we broke up Friday but like we're still
in love and we just know the
long-distance doesn't work I saw him
move out but then I saw you move back
together you're gonna have to make a
decision as to who's gonna go where
either you're gonna have to go live
there or he's gonna have to come back
here he shouldn't be there just so you
know so you can share that with him I
think he'll be moving alright I'm very
surprised I mean pretty well right on
each of these and it's really fun it's
super fun to tune into someone's heart
and tune into someone's soul to kind of
see where is that soul where's that soul
feeling love where are they first of all
thank you for trusting me thank you for
being honest with me thank you for
opening your heart to me and letting me
see your soul I really appreciate it I'm
just really excited for all of you
because I can see these glimmers of true
love for all of you and that's really
hard to find and to find it with all of
you is pretty pretty amazing so thank
you guys so much
[Music]